this week on world stories
greece
new hope
south sudan
reconciliation in a peace village
we begin in the middle east it's been
one year since the war in gaza between
israel and hamas
more than 2 000 palestinians and 72
israelis were killed in the conflict
we visited the war-torn region
this prosthetic limb is part of life now
for muhammad abu baid
he lost his left leg during the gaza
conflict last summer
and he's one of the lucky ones two of
his friends were killed in the air raid
already one year ago before the war
muhammad loved to play soccer
almost
as a soccer player i imagined all sorts
of other injuries
at the rehabilitation center he's still
learning to walk with the prosthetic leg
the fit is still not quite right so this
time he goes home without it
here in sejaya the aftermath of last
year's war is still very visible
large parts of the district were
destroyed by israeli
raids muhammad is here with a friend
for them the reconstruction process is
far too slow
everyone here has the feeling that
another war could break out at any
moment
maybe even in the very next moment
there's no such thing as a permanent
ceasefire that's something that israelis
on the other side of the border are all
too aware of as well
a few hundred meters away moran freibach
lives with his family during the
conflict a young boy was killed here by
a palestinian shell
this wall six meters high now protects
the local kindergarten
even recently there was a missile alert
here
i think
the
feeling of security right now haven't
changed a bit
since last year i think we're in the
same position as we were in the last
year and the summer before the war
[ __ ] says he believes in a political
solution to the conflict with the
palestinians but just how distant that
goal remains is clear from the bomb
shelters and fences that continue to be
built to protect israelis
back on the other side of the border in
gaza muhammad and his friends are trying
to find new purpose to their lives
soccer is no longer an option but other
kinds of sport still give them a strong
boost
on to south sudan where four years after
independence power struggles and
conflict remain the order of the day
a man of the cloth is doing his best to
stop that in the village of kuron
even experienced pilots have a hard time
finding the sandy landing strip
the region that bishop parid taban chose
for his peace project is one of south
sudan's most remote
residents of the village of kuran have
been waiting for several hours for the
clergyman's arrival
they say that since the bishop has been
involved here the whole region has
flourished and there has been less
fighting
the bishop says the concept is a simple
one
we bring people to self-reliance food
and so on
and bringing them new ideas especially
now with education vocational training
koran is located in an area that sees
bitter fighting among rival ethnic
groups mostly over access to pasture
land and cattle which are of primary
importance to the region's economy
the civil war that raged almost non-stop
for decades in south sudan brought
thousands of weapons into the country
ever since traditional cattle raids have
turned into violent conflict
bishop tawban finds the situation
unacceptable he has risked his life
countless times in the past few decades
to take part in peace talks and even at
the age of 79 he's still eager to work
hard under often grueling conditions
the bishop is especially proud of the
peace village's vocational training
center which he financed with church
donations from europe he mainly wants to
offer young men alternatives to fighting
and he's not afraid of getting his own
hands dirty carpentry skills are part of
a south sudanese bishop's job
description
when they see a building like that they
say wow
is it made by miracle
is it god who made it they don't know
that this human being who can make this
they think that they cannot do this or
when they see this oh these have been
done by some
european
might be some arabs who have been here
they destroyed because they think that
he's not done by one of them
but now when they learn that they know
that this is the work of their own hand
for a while now the village of quran has
hosted weddings between members of clans
that were previously bitter enemies
mary namuno a geo woman just recently
said i do to joseph lemoy a man from the
toposa tribe
at first my family was not happy that i
should marry a toposa man
but now they accept it
it's easier to cooperate than it is to
fight
that's also the message of a new play
from koran's drama troupe
newlywed mary nomuno has come to watch
along with almost everyone else in the
my village grave here
that's to show that i'm not going to
live here i retire only once in my life
and i'm going to retire here
until then the bishop still wants to
take care of a few things he wants to
build roads so that more people can come
to coron
and he still needs more time to
celebrate the progress that has already
been made
greece has been dominating the headlines
of late
deep in debt its economy in tatters is
there any hope
we met some young entrepreneurs in the
capital athens
it's exam time at athens university
these economic students are nervous of
course not only because of their grades
they're also worried about the situation
in their country
a lot of them fear that they won't be
able to find a job in greece after
they've graduated
to be quite honest i'm thinking of going
abroad
i don't want to leave
actually i'd rather live and work here
i'll try it but if it doesn't work out
i'm ready for anything
many of these students say a lot has to
change in greece that paying taxes
should be normal and civil servants
shouldn't have to be bribed to do their
job
it's not a matter of financial crisis so
it's not about the greek economy it's
about the greek way of thinking it's
about greek
culture and about greek mentality in
general this cannot be fixed with
eurogroup or with the imf or even with
the government we have right now
but others are determined to stay no
matter what the orange grove center is a
place where young greek entrepreneurs
can get together
88 startups now have office space here
although the center has only been up and
running for a year and a half janissaris
is one of them his big olive online
platform offers themed tours of athens a
niche market he previously lived in
sweden and spain but he was determined
to return home
believe it or not it's a country where
you know a private initiative can
actually be very rewarding because
you know you can become more flexible
and take advantage of all this potential
that happens so it was a very
conscious choice i like it here
antones argeros has also found a niche
he's developed software for trying out
clothes online
the program is selling especially well
in the middle east where women aren't
allowed to change their clothes in
publicly accessible areas
the 34 year old says greece is highly
competitive not least because its people
are extremely well educated and highly
trained
if you want to find a developer for
example in the u.s you have to pay him
three and four times what you pay here
in
the same developer so it's far more
cheaper to have all your tech teams here
the orange grove center was the
brainchild of dutch ambassador jan
festek who's celebrating with some of
the 140 people who now work here
unusual times ask for unusual
initiatives and we now have a situation
in which in europe people have very
strong prejudices about each other
there's a lot of negative atmosphere and
we thought let's do something positive
it's party time despite the country's
crisis
and these young entrepreneurs are hoping
that many more of their compatriots will
start their own businesses in greece
our final segment this week takes us
back to germany
world stories visits a clockmaker in the
heart of the black forest who's working
on a masterpiece destined for far away
mecca
a tower clock maker can climb tens of
thousands of stairs during a career the
clocks are usually huge and perched atop
tall towers this one rises 60 meters
above the town
it embodies an unbelievable amount of
knowledge handed down through
generations and it has to be made of
good compatible materials and they're
our company's secret
some of pero turmoiren's 30 employees
make replacements for broken dials some
of them put a gold leaf finish to clock
hands
the company employs clockmakers
mechanics locksmiths and blacksmiths
they all work together to produce things
like the brackets which suspend the
enormous clocks
the blacksmiths make spare parts for
various mechanisms like bell hammers
a new tower clock can cost as much as 40
000 euros
for this major order from mecca the
client had to pay family owned perro
several million euros the hour hand
alone was 17 meters long
the old dials in the company's 150 year
old archive are real treasures
they serve as models for the latest
order and are constantly being copied it
can take four to ten weeks to complete a
tower clock depending on its size
this clock is on its way to israel the
company's founder built the original
model in 1877
now it'll strike the time again in tel
aviv
you